so uh right now let's just let's let's
jump in i want to show you this first
story
from the milwaukee journal sentinel and
it's a really really amazing piece of
disinformation
and i also want to go through a bunch of
these like fake news journalists
smearing kyle rittenhouse it's it's it's
insane man
so earlier today as i mentioned donald
trump gave a press conference
where he said you know this kid looked
like he was being attacked and he may
have been killed if he didn't do
something
this is what the story says from the
milwaukee journal sentinel they say
trump mischaracterizes kenosha protest
shooting
defends rittenhouse evening written
house
evening before his visit to the city
roiled by unrest and violence
they say the president also
mischaracterized the incident
in which kyle rittenhouse was accused of
using an assault style rifle quote
that was an interesting situation you
saw the same tape that i saw
trump said monday during a white house
news conference he was trying to get
away from them i guess
looks like and he fell and they were
very v
and and they very violently attacked him
and it was something we're looking at
right now and it's under investigation
i guess he was in very big trouble he
probably would have been killed trump
added
i think i want to say at the point of
the evening the president describes the
teen had already shot and killed one
protester according to the charging
documents and video footage
trump's latest comment set the stage for
what could be a highly charged visit
from the most powerful man in the world
at a time when the community is still
recovering from a week of shootings and
unrest that left a black man paralyzed
two white protesters dead and businesses
looted and burned
so here's the first question i have i
think
i i'm just so tired of saying it they
don't have google do they i guess not
they don't they don't they listen all
too often
you've got three journalists on this
let me tell you a story i went to a
thing called news exchange once they
flew me out to morocco
and they had me up on a stage in front
of like a thousand journalists watching
and i looked around and i was asked
about like the state of journalism this
was back in 2012 and i said every single
journalist should be fired
every single one of them because they
have no idea what they're doing tech
wise they have no idea what they're
doing security wise
and there needs to be like a purge and a
start over and that was in 2012.
wow have things improved tim it's kind
of way worse
and and they got you know they were mad
yeah you know yeah so
someone from cnn tried offering me a job
and i was like are you joking
and it's funny because it was like 2012
so i was like kind of broke and just
they invited me there because i was
doing this coverage but anyway i bring
this up because
this story from the milwaukee journal
sentinel has three reporters
three reporters on this and not a single
person could have done a google search
over this quantity come on man i look
the people
the all of you listening probably did a
google search and found more information
than they did
so is it intentional that they're lying
specifically when they say
that trump mischaracterized the incident
and the
and their the the mischaracterization
their uh the mischaracterization
is they're saying at that point he
actually had killed somebody you see
they're omitting context to what trump
is saying
the new york times has the story i i'm
not sure where did i put there
there we go check this out first
shooting
while mr rittenhouse is being pursued by
the group an unknown gunman
fires into the air though it is unclear
why
the weapons muzzle flash appears in the
footage from the scene rittenhouse turns
toward the sound of gunfire as another
pursuer
lunges toward him from the same
direction written house then fires four
times
and appears to shoot the man in the head
you wanna know what's crazy about this
what's that four times they say the
medical examiner said he was hit five
times
so actually fact check me on that can
you pull that out i believe that's true
i'll look it up yeah
and one of the shots was in the back and
so
yeah i remember you telling me i tweeted
about this i i think the medical
examiner said you said five times so
make sure you connect your man though
because
this is work it's crazy the new york
times says he fires four times
okay maybe he only did i asked this
question on twitter
when when i took a screenshot from the
medical examiner's report
and it said he was hit you know once in
the back
and so i was like how did kyle
rittenhouse turn towards him as he was
lunging at him
and hit him in the back well they said
they said that they saw another muzzle
flash so i'm assuming that somebody else
was shooting as well
well what what what the new york times
is saying is the muzzle flash was fired
into the air could they be wrong about
that i mean it's far away
yeah it's it's i think that'd be that'd
be an amazing if that person's firing a
pistol from that range like they're
they hit him that's amazing yeah they're
good they're good they're not a fire
it's possible i mean i'm not a gun
expert or anything but
my question was how did he get hit in
the back and some people said if he was
lunging
and got hit and spun it would have
easily hit him in the back
but if they're saying did you find it no
i'm still looking
i think i have it on my twitter if you
like go through my twitter because i
tweeted i asked the question i think i
linked it but i could find it
yeah five five five balls you you look
that up and we'll keep talking about it
so anyway the point is
trump didn't mischaracterize it the dude
was being chased the new year i'm on the
new york times is the new york times not
credible enough
and what's which reporting should i
trust the milwaukee journal sentinel
that says
trump is lying that omits most of the
details of the incident or the new york
times that does a detailed breakdown
going through video after video i gotta
admit the new york times i think that
did a really good job on this one so he
turns toward the guy
and the guy lunges at him first okay
what do you think everybody
else said all these woke journalists oh
man i've lined up a bunch of tweets and
i have too many
here's a guy daniel dale says asked
about kyle rittenhouse
supporter accused of murder trump says
he's looking into it but adds
that was an interesting situation he was
trying to get away from them looks like
and then uh they very violently attacked
him he probably would have been killed
i've actually seen a lot of people very
critical of this tweet but
i don't i honestly don't see anything
wrong with it it's true uh written house
is accused of murder
i mean i would say that it looks like
self-defense but he was quite literally
charged
with it so this to me is kind of just
you know neutral but a lot of people
took issue because they want him to
bring up the greater context which i
believe would be a prudent to do he
didn't do it but i'm not going to
rag on him for just giving us a kind of
a bland quote from trump
however the recount trump not only
refuses to condemn
kyle rittenhouse the 17 year old who
killed two protesters
he defends him they violently attacked
him yeah yeah we get it
you know what i want to say something
because i was reading this account did
you find the thing yet no
it's on my twitter just scroll through
it i was reading this account from
a medic who was talking about the the
skateboard guy
who got shot by the kenosha kid and how
she ran to him
trying to render aid and that his
girlfriend was screaming
and i'm like yeah dude this is like this
is horrifying i'm sad for the dude i
don't want anybody to get hurt
the dude the skateboard should not have
gotten shot but
bro you don't run at a dude with an ar
laying on the ground and
grab the barrel of the gun and try and
pull on it that's suicidal
sure the the left is trying to claim
this guy was a hero or whatever but he
hit him over there with a skateboard
to what degree because because i'll tell
you this i watched the video
and it doesn't it it doesn't look like
he did a full swing bash
but at some point the skateboard comes
in contact with the kid's head
then he tries grabbing the barrel of an
ar i mean dude
at a certain point like you gotta back
away this kid's being chased
this is the big problem with mob
violence is that
i i've mentioned this scene in like uh
at the g20
i think it was the g20 where where luke
kowski got attacked oh yeah someone just
pointed at him and screamed nazi
and then random people started beating
him and he wasn't and and so what
happens if you're minding your own
business and someone screams that's the
guy
and they start attacking you then yeah
sure when they frame it like the
skateboard dude was a hero
i guess in the context where he had no
idea what was going on
and tried attacking a dude with a gun
sure you could argue that
but when you look at the bigger picture
of things where kyle was being attacked
and chased by a violent mob that was out
destroying property and
that dude did not live in kenosha either
i'm sorry man
it's not heroic to run up to a random
guy you have no idea what's going on and
try grabbing the barrel of a gun
well usa today was saying that the
victim in kenosha might have been trying
to save someone
and honestly i don't think it matters
what he was trying to do if he was part
of the mob that was not
seeing him which which guy wasn't
rosenbaum yeah that was the first guy
who got hit yeah another important thing
too is the medical examiner report said
he got a graze to the head not a
not a bullet through the head and i've
seen a lot of people claiming that
rittenhouse shot a guy in the head
and that was the initial tweet that went
out right people thought it was a
wholeness i haven't said the same thing
yeah it looked like medical examiner
said it was a great it was a graze oh
wow
yeah interesting and that he actually
died because i think it hit his his
internal organs right
yeah wow i didn't know that yep yep so a
lot of these people have no idea what's
going on and
and to be fair look i've got videos that
i did at the time which are inaccurate
at this point
like more information has come out and i
think that's why you know it's important
to track have you ever been able to find
it no i'm sorry on my twitter thread you
scroll down i did yeah keep going it's
there somewhere
all right here we go ryan savedra quote
tweeted this dude brian
ler what is it uh brian
cohen whatever oh brian tyler cohen is
his name yeah he said the adl looked
into written house and found
no indication from written house's
social media footprint that he is
connected to any extremist movements
okay the criminal complaint filed by
authorities said that ridenous was
attacked while running away
in which case oh i actually have the
article from the adl this will be
interesting
they say uh okay no this is just a cbs
i'm not going to read through the cbs
article because i think we've gone
through the gist of it but you get the
idea the adl
the anti-defamation league which tracks
extremist activity told cbs news
they were militia members at the kenosha
protest but found no indication from
written as a social media footprint
that he is connected to any extremist
movements his posts indicate
he's an extremely pro-police that he is
extremely pro-police
and appears to have been a former police
explorer a career-oriented program for
youth considering a career in law
enforcement
many of his social media posts use the
phrase blue lives matter oh my
according to the adl i'm assuming that
the adl thinks that some kind of hate
organization
if the adl has gone that far as to say
like
we didn't find anything there you go
yeah that is thorough that's pretty
pretty
the anti-defamation league has like a
really broad view of what right-wing
extremism is like
anti-government anarchists are
considered right-wing that's amazing to
me
yeah so i guess i i they call uh black
supremacy left wing
oh you know you want to know what they
what else they do when you go to their
um
page and you're looking at everything
they list is like hate speech or
hate organization like dog whistles or
something
um they have an entire list of numbers
and numbers and different sequences that
they consider
forms of hate speech i found it by the
way oh you did find it yeah i did find
it
oh okay it says serious question how do
you shoot someone in the front and the
back at the same time but the story is
the story's there right
you have a screen shot there's no link
no just what's up i forgot to link it
what kind of journalist can you can you
quote some of the text and then google
search it to find the article i'll do
that now because i'm pretty sure
the dude got hit five times i could be i
could be wrong about that so see what
you can find let me see
here we got a uh this is where it gets
fun we're just basically going through
tweets from people who are lying about
what happened
it's great lily adams says white house
has been given two chances to disavow
murder committed written murder
committed written house the first
presectary now trump
and has taken a pass both times so this
is actually really funny um
i mentioned that trump liked my twitter
thread and i've gone through it a couple
times but i'll give you the gist of it
because i think it's probably important
for me to explain like the point of what
i was saying
but kaylee mckennany was asked about it
and she said that trump's intent
was to highlight information that many
people probably didn't know
and yes and then trump was directly
asked about it he said basically the
same thing
but the gist of my thread okay it's
because i think it's like what uh 11
tweets
is that it ends my by with me calling
trump an a-hole
right but i'd rather vote for an a-hole
than a coward and i think it's
fascinating that trump liked the threat
i'm like hey
i think trump would find it funny back
all right i'll take it i think he said
something like that once didn't i think
he did yeah he was like i'm a mean guy
but i work for you
exactly so he probably laughed when he
saw it but the general idea is
i wrote cal rittenhouse is a good
example of why i decided to vote for
trump
violent extremists were destroying
people's lives for months 30 people were
killed
democrats rejected federal assistance
every time trump offered it
media lied about trump deploying secret
police okay so this is a
like a very broad brush i i posted here
i didn't say anywhere in the tweet
i supported kyle rittenhouse of course
that's an opinion
and they'll probably argue that because
i'm just reporting what the new york
times said
that is uh support for or defense of
what i should have said
is that the kyle renton house situation
is a good reason
right that you've got violent extremists
look at i said you know violent
extremists are destroying people's lives
democrats won't accept trump's help what
i was trying to say is
none of this should have happened the
kid shouldn't have had to have been
there exactly
he shouldn't have needed to be there
right and the police should have been
out there they shouldn't have been
trying to defund the
defund the police if the governor just
accepted
first i think the the the locals the
city council whatever asked for way more
national guard they did yes i recall
and the governor said no and trump's
repeatedly offered federal assistance
and they've all said no
it shouldn't have happened kyle should
not have had to have been called
by anybody to go out there i think it
was foolish that he went out there
because
look man you like i've been on the
ground with these violent riots
i've seen what these people do and you
need to that kid probably didn't
understand the likelihood that he was
going to pull the trigger was like
99.9 yeah well he's a 17 year old kid
he's just kind of going out there to
have fun
nothing's ever gonna happen to a teen
nothing's ever going to happen nothing's
ever going to go wrong
well he had he had good intentions right
the path the hell is paved with good
intentions exactly the problem is
how do you where where's the there's
there's no way to call this one
right do you just let violent extremists
destroy your town
these people weren't from there by the
way the kenosha issued a statement
saying out of 100
i think 175 arrests 102
were out from outside the city right and
so was he but he worked in kenosha
i'm sure they some of them all were
outside from outside the city but had
some reason
you know to be familiar with the place
but it's you know
do you do nothing do you just sit back
and say well i guess i lose my business
in my life or do you say i need help the
police aren't helping me
and then to what degree do we blame kyle
for being a 17 year old kid who was
asked by locals can you help protect
businesses
and this kid loves cops and he's
probably like dude this is awesome
yeah and he was rendering aid to the
writers even right well he
he started the day by scrubbing off
graffiti and cleaning the mess up in
kenosha
and i don't know the only thing that i
can come up with to say is that even if
you do decide that you need to step in
and do something about it you sure as
heck don't send a 17 year old kid
you try to make sure that people who are
responsible and mature
and have a firm grasp of the situation
and aren't running around in cowboy
boots which are really is that what he
was doing
yeah i think he had cowboy but that's
why he fell down yeah
yeah no way no way i don't believe that
is that is that for sure i'll look it up
but hold on
let me let me throw a little uh a little
um uh
counter point your way in that regard we
send 18 year olds overseas
to to to kill people that's fair and
this kid
he worked in this in the town is a 17
year old not allowed to defend his own
community
i i think he is but i have a
counterpoint to your counterpoint
because the 18 year olds that we send to
fight wars are led by people who have
experience that's where i'm mature and
there's as far as i can tell there's not
really anybody like that there
and they go through they go through
extensive training right i mean the
written house looks like he had he had
yeah i think
he trained yeah good trigger yeah yeah
yeah i actually was talking to a friend
of mine who said that
she felt what proves intent to kill was
trigger discipline you can't yeah yeah
because because he knows how to handle a
weapon
and his finger clearly wasn't on the
trigger most the time that means he made
the decision to move his finger to
firing position to shoot those people
and i was like yeah yeah to defend
himself yeah
they're coming at you they have weapons
in their hands
not just a skateboard man this is this
is this is crazy but anyway it takes out
this work it's funny
so that dude brian tyler or whatever
yeah mike cernovich
quote tweets him saying nick sandman's
lawyers represent kyle rittenhouse enjoy
those retweets because you're literally
going to be paying money for them
and then the tweet got deleted and i
guess he re he reposted it with a
cleaner
uh statement huh yeah yeah so so you
can't
really sue someone for defamation if
it's an opinion you know
so the tweet went away and i guess it's
not the only one a bunch of other people
did too
is there so screenshot here here's the
screenshot we're going to demonetize
because we got some swears in here says
holy s trump is defending kyle
rittenhouse
he's defending a white supremacist who
murdered two people in cold blood
he defended him from the lectern at the
white house
you know man i don't know how we're
supposed to have a functioning
society if people just make stuff up
and just you know you know what the
craziest thing is
ultimately they want to get to here is
the gas lighting with joe biden
how he's basically joe biden came out
and says he's condemned
violence on both sides and is
challenging trump to do the same
and it's like when trump the last time
he said there were
bad people on both sides and some fine
people on both sides they turned it into
a smear they've used non-stop
joe biden did it's so ironic that joe
biden is bringing this up because
he kicked off his campaign talking about
the very fine people hoax
and he's like president trump you know
he really likes him some uh
white nationalists or whatever and he's
never let go of it and
he's bringing it up again now well now
what biden's doing is a clever
you know linguistic manipulation yeah so
instead of saying
trump called white nationalist this he
says remember what they looked like and
remember what he said
then he says the quote so he can't be
sued for lying pretty clever
it is because it'd be funny if trump
sued biden for defamation in a political
race it's
very amazing no it would it's it's like
the judge would laugh and be like
welcome to politics grow up you're 74
like you're beyond an adult wait so can
you you can sue for defamation if you're
a famous person though right yeah it's
harder though
okay so um i mean will chamberlain who
i've actually
got one of his tweets is a better uh
a better person to talk to but he'll be
on the show i think when is he coming
on the 9th oh yeah i've had will on my
show so many times
oh yeah but uh my understanding
basically having talked to will several
times who is a lawyer
is you have to prove if if you're a
public figure and someone defames you
you have to prove they knew what they
were saying was false ah
it's extremely difficult yeah how do you
prove someone's intent
messages emails but even then
you know i think for for a lot of this
stuff these people are just you know
kind of really dumb
yes and there's not going to be internal
communications between
for a guy who just tweets something out
right so proving actual mass
now i guess the big issue is when it
what's becoming really challenging with
these defamation suits
is that everyone is a public figure now
yeah so when it came to nick sandman
so for those of there he's the covington
kid who was standing on the steps of the
lincoln memorial
the native american guy walked up to him
started banging the drum in his face and
then the media smeared him he's won a
bunch of settlements by the way
but uh the trouble with him was they
tried arguing he was an involuntary
public figure
and they were writing about him because
it was the news and he's a public figure
and i guess his legal team argued
against that saying he didn't do
anything to be a public figure
yeah yeah no that's a thing it is yeah
yeah so uh they argued the kid didn't
say anything you can't set that standard
that's insane
but that's where it's getting dangerous
is kyle rittenhouse now a public figure
because he's all over the press
and social media i think it's ridiculous
to try and argue he is
he's because he didn't say anything to
anybody you know
well no yeah i would say i'm really
really happy that
um britton house is being defended by
nick salmon's lawyer
that gives me a great deal of confidence
in what's going to happen and the sheer
amount of video
around this incident yep there's no i
don't there are
there are two new videos that have
surfaced
which make the circumstance really
interesting the first is that apparently
after the shooting one of the guys who
is with kyle rittenhouse says
the police told us they were going to
block it off and then send everyone our
way because we could deal with it
so i tweeted about that and i'm like
dude the kenosha p
and it's the answer for this because
that sounds like they set them up
seriously and i don't mean set them up
like a bunch of cops were like i got a
plan to frame a kid what i'm saying
is it's an extreme interpretation of
what i'm trying to say what i'm trying
to say is the cops knew they were kids
down there armed and were like
send the writers that way and i'm like
i'm not saying they had a grand scheme
or grand intent it was literally just
like
they knew the kids were there and they
thought send the writers that way
not not negligence yeah see those are
the adults that i would have expected to
have
taken up like the mantle of being
responsible for these kids
and they didn't it looks like they
really failed them i think i think the
point you made is is
is you know earlier is exactly it well
while we do have young people who go
overseas to fight wars
they have commanders they have like they
have the chain of command
right they have training and guidance
this kid probably did have a lot of
training but
no one on the ground was seemingly in
control the situation
i'd imagine if they actually had someone
older and more experienced he could have
called them
told them like here's what we do here's
how we do it here's when we move and if
they were together
he wouldn't have been chased yeah so you
had a handful of kids
and they weren't experienced enough so
when when rittenhouse got got attacked
and chased the other guys should have
been there
to help him out but there's so there's
another video so it's there's that one
but there's another one where
after the first guy gets shot kyle is
running and someone said what happened
what's going on and kyle says i'm
running to get the police
oh wow yeah and then people start
yelling get him get him stop him
and then they start attacking him the
kid was running for the police
and they attacked him oh yeah so you
know it is it is
it really is an interesting uh conundrum
first and foremost none of them should
have been out past curfew yep
but uh uh yes yes no they should none of
them should have been out past curfew
i give a little bit more leeway to the
kids because they were there in a
defensive
you know for as right protect the
businesses
render aid it was going to happen the
rioters shouldn't have been out there
rioting
so i think the fact that they were out
there burning down buildings
not this group specifically but just in
general negates this idea that the
skateboard guy
was a hero yeah so so if if we can if we
take into account that the kid who is 17
shouldn't have been out there
with his gun then the protesters should
surely should not have been out there
either
like we have to apply the same standard
the so
the issue right now that i'm seeing like
the way cnn is framing it and the
friends
of like and these leftists is that the
skateboard guy
by himself sees a dude running down the
street with an ar and they're screaming
he just killed somebody
and so in his mind he was like oh man i
gotta stop this guy before he hurts
someone else
you see what i'm saying sure yeah the
problem is that guy wasn't out there
with
good intentions right so i'm you know
if you go out with the intent to riot
see someone running on the street and
then you attack them
i'm sorry dude that's not heroic you
don't know what happened you don't know
who you're attacking
and that's actually it's interesting to
me that i've talked to
a lot of people about the good guy with
the gun scenario you have a lot of
conservatives say how do you stop a bad
guy with a gun a good guy with a gun
and many of them said the reason it's a
bad idea is that if everyone starts
attacking each other the cops have no
idea who's the good guy or the bad guy
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time